mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir au micro léon zitrone mon propos
ne sera pas de vous dire maintenant
pourquoi tout à l'heure ce cher les ont
abattus la pauvre a dit non ça c'est une
affaire un peu de ce que je voudrais
vous dire plutôt c'est que dans quelques
instants vous pourrez suivre en direct
sur vos écrans grâce aux caméras de
bernard lions entre parenthèses cher
bernard lions qui se défend comme un
lion et cela je le souligne car je suis
très à cheval sur les principes de bonne
camaraderie qui nous unissent donc cette
course le grand prix de pinottes vendeur
ou depuis des cacahuètes si vous
préférez c'est beaucoup plus simple va
mettre en présence de grandes favorites
de plein champ c'est du grand favorite
qui du haut de la tribune les aperçoit
maintenant sont rangés dans leurs boxes
de le départ je vois à ma gauche
nini belge l'univers genre kazakh
bariolés zune est en couleurs kazakhes
noir et blanc sur des zones noires et
blanches cette mini belle jambe
actuellement et bien entraînée par
monsieur bruno et à sa droite vous
reconnaissez l'opulente crinière de
dalida la morose à dany zamir a dit elle
j'ai coin est entraînée par ne sors je
ne crois pas j'en suis sûr entraîné par
monsieur arland aux international show
bien alors tandis que je parle et bien
le départ lunettes redonner c'est à un
train extrêmement rapide qu'est la
concernant mais je vous laisse le soin à
certains spectateurs ne jugez vous mêmes
nous est extraordinaire et ça paie
bravo dalida à je dois dire que de
mémoire de turfiste on n'a jamais vu une
si belle envolée je vous laisse juger
mais non messieurs donnait pas dans
lequel se retrouveront les deux
pouliches à l'arrivée en direct de
grand-champ c'était bien aux icônes
avoue bernard lions